it's Oscar time so let's get ready with
the official Oscars app from nominations
morning up to the unprecedented
backstage access of the show we have
everything you need to become the
ultimate Oscar insider this is your
backstage pass here you can get breaking
news and exclusive sneak peeks of what's
in store for this year's show the app
has everything you need to know about
the nominees and also features the
official my pics game where you can
predict the winners and compare scores
with your Facebook friends as they are
updated in real-time with exclusive
videos giving you tips from the pros on
oscar predictions Oscar party tips red
carpet fashion previews into the big
show and much more you'll be ready to
enjoy Oscar night like never before then
on Oscar night this app gives you a
backstage pass to the red carpet and
behind the scenes of the 85th Academy
Awards all for free with over a dozen
live backstage and red carpet video
streams you get the best view of the
action it's the perfect companion to
have when watching the show on ABC call
your own shots and direct mode to
control what cameras to view or if you'd
prefer to simply sit back and relax
switch to watch mode as our
correspondents take over and guide you
through the ultimate Oscar experience
invest of all with a VIP guest list and
millions watching you can join the party
using hashtag Oscars Oscar season has
begun start the celebration here with
the official Oscars app available on
iPhone iPad Android and kindle